[Music]
hey what's up this week's winners on a
Wednesday we have Christian Rivera I met
Christian I've been friends with him for
about five years now when we met he was
a professional footballer he's now
retired and has done a remarkable thing
in properties built himself a portfolio
and it's just a real pleasure after
known him for five years to have on the
show my man Christian well thanks thanks
having me great to have you on the show
man yeah we've we've been we got back a
long one yeah
what do you just kick off and just give
us a little background about yourself
yeah well basically I've I was born in
Swansea came across when I was seven
eight years old in the Gloucestershire
and I joined Bristol City's Academy when
I was about nine ten years old came
through all of that an infant by age 16
you then go into youth team level so you
go away from school you go into
full-time and at that point I was and
then that stage was probably sort of the
next best thing in Bristol that I was
getting big opportunities and yeah I was
sort of pushed to the first team at ages
16 and 1/2 17 so really early and I
thought this is easy you know I could
just do it I didn't worry too much about
everything else I just every step that
was given in front of me I could just go
on and do it and over time things were
getting better and better for me I
started stepping close to the first team
I had opportunities to go to Premiership
clubs and things at 18th like a
million-pound which back then was a lot
of money I was 10 years ago now so I was
a lot and I was playing for Wales and
there's like insanity you played for
Wales and yeah I did later on this is at
the younger age I was 17 painfully under
21 so I was doing that was probably when
I was at my peak of potential and then
only when I was 18 I made my debut at
Bristol City who were championship-level
which is really good then and I did my
knee 20 minutes in out of nowhere just
twisted following a player and I didn't
Maci I'll really badly down with my
cartilage and I was out for a year and
to be honest after that I was never the
same again and I still managed to have a
career played ten more years I mentioned
play for Wales internationally when I
was 20 and thing but I just deteriorated
over time and I wasn't react very well
and I was a very athletic player so once
I lost some of that in my knee my career
never reached the same level that I
wanted it to I'm going to talk to you
more a bit about football and a bit
about what happened to that you read a
book which Dad Poor Dad we do
like the book that often brings people
in to learn investments then what
happened well I think I'm I started
getting into that sort of
self-development so when I knew I could
see my career was coming to an end I
wasn't going to achieve what I wanted to
and I guess I need to look further ahead
and that was one of the first books I
read going onto self-development all of
this side and straightaway like a lot of
people say it's like a light bulb going
on I thought right this is something
I've got a game - I get involved and
that's how I bought my first property at
19 and I had some success with that
through some capital growth in Bristol I
already had some knowledge and
experience and some money back from that
and I thought well I'm already rolling
in this direction why don't I go a bit
so you bought a house when you were 19
and then you saw that that shot up in
value yeah and now you're thinking I've
got a dodgy knee I've made money in
property that's gone really well I need
to learn how to do that and that's kind
of I think a lot of people start in
property accidentally don't know they
have to live somewhere excetera so when
I was 19 I was on a really good contract
and I bought a two-bed apartment centre
of Bristol that was really lovely locate
Bristol's a brilliant city you know
great a great place and it's growing all
the time so I bought there thinking I
know my money safe and I love living
here I was working five minutes down the
road Bristol City football ground so I
was like a great place but then in five
succeded went up like a hundred grand
yeah now I didn't expect that at the
time and I didn't know what I was doing
as such I was just living there I knew
it was a good idea but that then just
triggered in brains look if you know if
you have follow the right fundamentals
being in good areas good properties look
what can happen you know yeah and that's
awesome and I taste something you little
secret were I believe attended my very
first property investors crash course
and I think that's it's mad isn't it
when you look back five years incredible
but that's when I started to take it
more seriously I started to look into
truly what I wanted to achieve in
property and what you can achieve and I
think back then when I was due I bought
a couple places in Bristol before then
that was more I liked Bristol had money
from footballs on a good contract well
I'll just Park it which and that's the
beautiful thing of property I'll
forgiving it is that even if you're not
an inner demon expert on it it's still
you know those of them really well for
me over time and now effectively
all my money's pulled out of them and
I'm using it for others but I did that
without
at the time I just didn't know a great
place to be I loved there I know other
people over time love to live there and
it's been really forgiving but the thing
is that you were smart enough even
though you didn't know exactly what you
were doing you bought a property at 19
a lot of footballers they're not even
they don't even thinking about this so
so yeah and I know now you're really
passionate and one of the reasons you've
come on the show is because you're
really passionate about helping and
inspiring other sports people and saying
look you make it really good money now
but that's not last forever right
exactly and I think part of the reason
I'm so passionate about is because I'm
the biggest case study I you know I know
of going through it where I had that
opportunity of being like a premiership
player or having a brilliant career I
didn't achieve that through injury and
overtime my career was deteriorating I
was retired by 27 you know I just turned
20 I'm 29 now and I was retired early
and I was on a good wage but I wasn't on
a crazy wage where I could never have to
work again luckily I built up there's
you know a modest portfolio over time
and I learned unto other bits now
running into some other business but
lots of people don't have that they
don't think that until it's too late and
so many stories you know I don't need to
go into them out of here the
bankruptcies and all of this and people
I know that I've got big mortgages that
if they if they were dropped from that
club but they didn't have a team for
next year you won't be able to afford
their mortgage they're on five grand a
month mortgages and things like that
it's incredible and some P what people
don't realize but it is coming to the
fore now is the stats for people were
time from sport are incredible think
depression is three times more likely in
sports on to the national average
bankruptcy for more than 40% of them are
bankrupt in the first five years that's
incredible I think divorce is something
like a third of them are divorced in the
first 12 months 75 percent in the first
three years these are incredible stats
as well
they're glossed over because why do you
think that more professional footballers
and generally just sports people why do
you think that more of them don't invest
Wow into property I think I think you'll
understand something people you meet
when when people are in more money
doesn't it necessarily mean they're
smart with it you find that expenses go
up with income that's how a lot of
people live so the fact some zoning I
know for ground the month to earn in 100
grand a month
200 grand sending these guys are in
crazy money's but they do spend it you
know they live in their life yes they'll
probably have some input but
you feel invincible when you're playing
but surely you know when you're a
footballer and you're making really good
money you know it's not gonna last
forever say that but you know I
experienced it as well I was lucky to
some extent that I had a major injury
very young so I had that so that you say
you just said I'm lucky that I had an
injury very early on that's a very
positive mindset the negative is at 27 I
was told I'll never run again all this
other stuff so I've got you know serious
issue but from that side of his the
mentality was then I thought I was
invincible I was just gonna make you I
was gonna be you know I never have to
work again
suddenly going back down to earth but
grounded me a little bit and some people
and they don't actually get that until
they retire that's when it's tough but
now what you're saying is you shouldn't
have to be injured to realise that you
need to stop investing some people some
are more receptive to it and than others
and you have to remember as well in
football compared to spoil like rugby
footballers generally they come from
low-income backgrounds and not as
well-educated generally so when they
come into money they're not educated our
two little spend money so nowadays
there's guys like agents and financial
advisers that will literally control
what the player earns almost is in the
money's coming in they say no you can't
have that that's going over here because
that's what you spend because the Lance
they just focus on football there one
thing football football football and
that's great and because they want to
achieve their goals yet that's all
they've ever wanted to achieve but when
things start going wrong and you'll find
quickly in sport it's very fickle you
know when you're out nobody cares about
you nobody looked after me when I was
retired and I didn't get any insurance
payout any of that stuff so when I
retired that was me done 27 my well I
built my whole life towards that's a
start a new journey but just like that
not there's not no one out there we when
they finish a job they still got those
skills to be able to take our swear and
you're a footballer you haven't got any
more skills you know that's me gone I
can coach football that's about it what
advice would you give to somebody who
was a footballer or someone who's in a
potentially short-term good because any
career short-term if it's not if you're
not getting passive income what advice
would you give to them to how to get
started you have to start everyone talks
about education and there's so many
resources out there and people that are
really inspirational that you can go out
and learn you know we use in properties
of vehicle that we love and I push think
it's the best vehicle out there to
create that financial freedom or that
opportunity to increase your value your
wealth etc but you know they've just got
a start and it starts from one step
doesn't it the first book you read it's
not like you're gonna be an expert
overnight nobody is but these guys do
have potential to have wonderful you
know safety cushions at the end of their
career and things they're almost you
know if they've got ten years after they
retire what a fantastic position to be
in build that portfolio build those are
the skills that you have so when you
retire at 35 you already moving
you're not standstill when you suddenly
your incomes going they actually can
soften the blow of that and and work the
way into other things very steady in
your approach like I know my men told
you for a year in property for the year
of 2015
and you're very steady in you approach
but over over the five years you've now
got and you still say I'm just I'm still
in my early days you still say that but
you've grown something pretty remarkable
are you full timing property yeah so we
now basically from that I wanted to
build something that would help me
sports when whilst you know I achieve my
own goals hugs but I'm interested before
when you retire at 27
I'm not finished I want to do something
else now I feel like my career I didn't
achieve what I wanted to so now I want
to achieve in another aspect and I can
help those in my community that I know
but nobody gave me the help so I want to
help those give better and then for
myself as well build something for
myself and basically me I have a
business partner now we're based up
towards Manchester where we have their
bespoke portfolio building service for
sportsmen and one or two others what's
we're doing our own stuff as well so now
that's what we're growing at what's an
average day then for you what does an
average day look like today well
normally I'm spending most of my time up
north now you know I lived and
Cheltenham way so I used to all my life
have been travelling so now I spend a
lot of time at Manchester Way and a lot
of is as you know people people who do
really well in property it take actions
and they so days will be calling agents
will be viewings it'll be solicitors
brokers because our model we have is we
have a an end-to-end convey about almost
words we have the broker solicitors tax
counters to get people ready to buy then
we have all the agents accepted to help
us find the deals that work then we have
the contractors to do the refurbishment
we own or let an agency to let out at
the end so it's a lot of moving parts
and and you know you do that because it
because firstly it helps you because you
need the people in the team but then if
other people can tap into it as well
let's see it
you know what we've got there's lots of
messages in there but we're trying to
create hands-free system that's going to
give you really great returns long term
etc but you're getting high quality
through all because these people we've
hand-picked over time through experience
yeah I think between me my best partner
we own over 60 houses so we know what
we're talking about and when we pick the
strategies etc we're able to go back
over ten years of performance in
portfolio to say these types houses work
best not the ones in the poor areas that
we got really cheap they haven't gone up
in capital value in ten years in the
goods that's know go to the better area
spend a little bit more here because
they went up eighty hundred grand over
ten years not ten grand
that's where you make your life-changing
amounts of money and that message you
can only get when you've got experience
and experiencing is invaluable it's
interesting because I know you've you've
dabbled in lots of different types of
approach I know you've done hate your
nose you've done sing all that you've
bought up north you've bought down south
and you've now you've now been got a
strategy that suits you that works for
your goals so and I think a lot of it
exactly a lot of its goal orientated and
you have to think when you go through
the experience we wanted to build
something that not only can give you
really good returns but you want to
downside protection of it you want to
make sure that for someone like the
sportsman if they build a port for they
don't want have to be going in every two
years and sorting issues out you want
something that smooth gives you
consistent income because they can rely
on it later exactly they're going to
rely can certain so we've looking at the
different strategies and think no I
think what we believe in is adding value
to properties we we love a single let
model because one that fantastic wealth
builds from capital growth you get
opportune to add value to them you know
by buying tired things that will do
really good jobs on in create equity and
what a way to build a portfolio where
they're almost like the foundation of
everyone's report for they give you a
consistent income you get that capital
growth and over time you just compound
it don't you buying great areas buying
areas that you can see a growing and
when you're doing it full-time we are on
the ground we know which areas are going
up we know where there's big family
demands where there's good schools all
this when you follow those you find that
that's where you can really do some
great things
so what are you buying right now so we
now are doing a number of things so
we've got guys for the sports win that
we're basically doing this whole
portfolio building service for so we're
generally buy tired properties at a
discount then we do really brilliant
refurbs and then we to be honest the
guys sometimes will refinance quickly
sometimes won't because those guys don't
need the money today so they're what
they're trying to build is really pots
of you know wealth over they'll come and
realize in ten years so there's a mixed
bag there's some real and sometimes
exact and I think that's something
everyone is different and sometimes you
don't want to leverage yourself up to
the eyeballs you want to be able to know
that no I've got equity sign in there
and if you if you spend ten grand a
reefer I want to add twenty thirty grand
a value you know that's still your money
it's in the property never lost it it's
there and that's that that's the beauty
of finding things doing a great job in
the design that we do in the contract so
we do it still on a good budget because
it has to be on a right budget but you
can add so much value and when you
create these lovely houses for people in
good solid areas you find that the
demand just going up and up and up and
we've just tried to combine that with
fundamentals of why do we make these
certain areas so we go to Manchester
because Manchester is having one of the
most biggest investment cities in the
country and there's so much is pool and
into Manchester and then we're looking
what areas have great transport links
great employment and they're big you
know if we got we're down in the south
side where's a bit more capital grow so
in Stockport we do a lot of our stuff no
I I'm weirdly I was on loan at Stockport
when I was 18 years old and back then
that was ten odd years ago and it was
you know a bit dreary not so good now
there's a plan to spend over billion
pounds in regeneration over the next
five years they've got the Manchester
airports having over billion pounds in
terminals you know all the changes there
which is five minutes down the road ten
minutes into centre Manchester to two
hours director London people don't know
about all these things combined thing
what a great place to be for the next
five ten years and I didn't know that
years ago and most people don't say they
only look at the top line stuff when you
start delving deeper you could see why
people were doing it full-time they have
the time to learn go go into here you'll
be really happy you did in five ten
years you know and that's that's the
levels that have people have to think
about them when they start coming into
tens of thousands of pounds what are
your thoughts on things like the economy
right now bricks there and and 2019
well to me I always believe man i know
i've heard from yourself as the in
property you buy in holt
you know there's never a better time to
buying property in my opinion than today
there's still opportunities today then
there will be if a market dip 20% and
you think all great
bargains still opportunity today to out
value and to create things because still
buying in areas that people need homes
and need great quality homes so there's
always opportunities out there I
actually think that once it settles this
breaks are whichever way we go with it
it sells
I actually think there'll be more of a
spring rather than a dip so much it's so
that I think people like security when
when things sound go right we're going
this way I think you'll find that things
will pick up a little bit again but the
way we think of is well how can we down
you know protect against any downside
well add value so you've always got good
equity and stuff and you've got the cash
flow because things cash folks you never
need to sell because of cash flow issues
well then you can withstand anything
you're building this bulletproof
portfolio in essence which that's what
everyone something yeah so what would be
your what would be your message are you
were the first football arrival worked
with so I mean when you came on I love
like you know it was a really cool it
was a really cool thing I've now worked
with a lot of footballers you work with
sports people what would be your message
in a few words to say to these sports
people that haven't thought about
investing or what you know what would be
your message as to why they should
educate themselves and what watch is
that it I think you've got to start
educating so and you know you're gonna
learn everything is about learning
stages I would never say jump in two
foot into something that you don't know
learn you know research from people from
strategies but you've got to get going
as well there's so many people I know
and then just don't take action you know
and I think that we spoke work for the
people do really well to always take an
action and so I know guys who because I
played with two years ago and they're
interested in property and I'll call
them talk about and say oh how are you
getting I've got it it's like no I
haven't got anything on you missed two
years of capital growth and cash flow
etc and these people that you've got
your money starting banks and yes okay
you can have your cash ice things
alright fine
but it's not that exciting to be honest
to stuff like that and whilst you're not
spending it you loo it's it's losing its
buying power and you know you could put
it into a car you could close your eyes
and buy something at state a today and
you'll do all right over time you know
you're gonna do it so turn that on to
somebody who really is looking for the
extra one percents here and there that's
where you make your real monies and your
real growth so sometimes it's about
something to take action
look I started off as an accidental
landlord by just buying live in and it's
ended up doing me pretty well
so just you've got to take action with
it what did you think of the crash
course when he came yeah well when I
came then I was very much starting out
so everything was still relatively new
and you can see all the excitement of
people and I was just starting out then
so I was starting to build my portfolio
and things so just opened your eyes to
the amount of opportunities are out
there yeah but you still got to work for
them you know it's about those
opportunity I would work really hard to
you it's nice to see those I think over
time you see the ones who are still
going five years later you can shape it
all eight out of ten months still go and
those two why are they still going
because they kept doing those action
they kept going they kept going and they
had some really good values in their
fundamentals that meant that five years
later look for yourself look look at how
you've you know exploded your growth and
I can use that as well to see the other
people who were doing smaller things and
they're not doing so much now yeah so
you say that you're in a superb case
today your football career talk to me
about that so basically the reason I'm
so passionate about and the sports was
when I look back at my case study and we
talked about some of the things that
footballers go through when in return
when I retired I went for an insurance
claim for the PFA which probably and I
don't mind to it would probably be
something like twenty thirty forty
thousand some like that and I was
rejected they said no they said it was
wear and tear on my knee they wouldn't
even though I had a good case for why it
wasn't they wouldn't look at it so I
went from a well paid job suddenly I had
six months wages overtime mid season so
I had six months where they had two one
on the contract and that was it as my
foot grow over and in that time me and
my partner split up just like we talked
about all this divorce and all this
stuff my long-term partner split at the
time so I went through all these
emotions luckily I had amazing family
and friends so I never went through that
depression side of it but certainly my
life was turned upside down you know I
went from being a pro football noted in
Cheltenham enjoying life in and never
worrying about my knees oh so suddenly
everything's changed my whole life has
gone as change so then when I looked at
who was there to help me only my family
and friends really all the other
institutions out there that around the
sportsman nobody helped me to be honest
with you and it was lucky that I
invested when I did when I was younger
because that softened the blow for me
something I wasn't on 0 pounds I had
other investments that were paying me
monies and I had other equities and
think that's what saved me and and
look back now and think that was so
lucky that I I think of that as almost
lucky that I was thinking about later on
earlier on in my career and so now when
I when I talked about it I've lived it
I've lived going through a time and only
I've lived through the negative sides of
it the divorce side of it all this stuff
I've lived it I understand what it's
like I've been through it I'm telling
you this is where you want to be
thinking because this will soften that
for you and it's always going to be hard
to go through that but this is about how
to make as best you can for yourself and
your family
fantastic well I've really loved seeing
you progress over the last five years
and I'm really honored to have been able
to serve in some way and it's just great
to have afraid to how your house is
doing any more of a house yeah so now
we've we had what I had some that were
how shares before and I think again we
talked about owning houses for over ten
years so I could see the good and bad of
everything well things are when well
things were so when I owned those I had
them as a house share at the time for
bed and they went really well for a year
I thought great this is easy as I did in
that sort of naivety when you think
empties then you start out a few issues
so I have a void period then a tenant
issue or a bit of damage by the
maintance quickly you start reading on
these aren't performing as they should
so now I actually turn it around put
them back to single let's and said no I
want the consistency of having X amount
per month that I don't have to worry too
much about I still get the capital
growth and I can rely on that if I see
interesting it's really interesting
because so you rot you'd rather make
three four hundred pound consistently
rather than seven eight hundred pound
but then you've got a big problem
problem at about ten exactly and what
you find this with a lot of those the
reality is when you put in your cost in
maintenance you find that one void can
knock it down to less than single debt
levels and to voice only AB losing money
well that's so I experienced that I sort
of came to a decision while at my time
my life and I didn't want to let manage
them full-time myself they were distant
from me excited you know what I just
wanted a steady amount that I can rely
on I know the good houses I tidy them up
they're nice houses and I said no I just
get sit on them now I mean let the
capital growth over time I mean we know
those how they doing only comes to a
growth point of view I'd say they've
gone up over the last twelve years maybe
15 20 grand nothing spectacular but what
we found now is the ones that we're
doing in different areas for different
reasons they're going up that's you know
ten twenty three and in a year because
we're in the right areas where Noah
spots so now we're in Stockport May
and some surrounding areas so so some of
those areas run their monster we haven't
really big growth in breeding big
demands so the ten we're finding in our
projects we're breaking market values
and breaking market rents because we do
a lovely property no we we do a lot of
really nice refurbs might be my bishop I
really diligent on getting the most for
our monies and doing lovely standard and
people pay for that in the nicest way
they want to live in nice homes so
they'll rent an extra hundred pound over
the market value and when we just did
our first flip and it sold on first view
and we had it I think we put it on on
the Wednesday on the Saturday was an
open day and all these people came we
had all these offers and it went for 20
grand over asking price and you made
like 60 grand gross I know so that when
we bought it for 120 and sold for 180
within three months of each other so it
was really quick and I know I don't want
with profit on it something something
halfway between that you know something
like that because that's fees and
especially in this market of uncertainty
the fact that you're able to and the
reason we were able to because we know
the areas I know this was a really hot
area because of my relationships with
agents the great thing is about you
though now is before you were kind of
dabbling with property you were focusing
on your football career your football
career was really bright at one point
when that ended but now you've got a
really bright property career and you
kill men vision then for say five years
where do you really want to be well I
think in everything in probably our Amos
we're still the proofs in the pudding we
still buy properties like we're doing
now we're on three or four own sites
grad now so we are doing the same as
what we're doing the sportsman so when
they say you know you're doing it for
them yeah we're building our own
portfolio we're buying in we're buying
in the street next to you and all of
that stuff so we're doing the same thing
so we just want to keep building our own
legacy of port forwarding getting better
and better over time we might change
strategies a little bit and maybe go for
apartment block and bits and bobs like
that but at the minute we decide to be
laser-focused and go for one strategy
and off that we do the flips and bits
off it but it's the same threat we buy
tide houses that we turn something
really good and generally the single
that stuff and what let's do 2030 let's
become an expert to that become an
expert in that feel and try and be
almost we're hoping to be the biggest
buyer in that area so when when of that
type of deal comes on as they stand to
do now they they call up and tell Chris
we've got another one of ones like you
know down the road
you guys want it that's what we want to
get to and you have to prove yourself
together there takes time to get to that
point what do you think of some of the
deals that we're doing at the moment
yeah I know it's incredible isn't it and
this sense it's really inspiring to see
other bits sometimes as well it can be a
bit of an egg to be thinking oh that's
amazing why can't I do that but it's
true if you want to do more doesn't it
and and every and every deal has got
strengths and weaknesses so when you see
someone do a rent or anything that's
brilliant
you know for you if you're going to
manage that you get the cash flow but
then you have your negative you don't
get your capital side of it so
everyone's got different goals Evan they
so you know what there's no necessarily
right you Sai are preferred to buy and
slightly more expensive areas of capital
appreciation and for less of a headache
other people say well I can get a
similar issue rent by everyone's got
their own thing and I think it's just
about and I said this too when I first
started mentoring you in 2015 I said buy
one or two test it but you know because
you don't go crazy but I want or to test
it and in buying it and you slowly
develop your own strategy you've now got
your Christian ROI birria Christian my
Barrow's strategy which is taken 5 10
years yeah exactly to put together exact
and that's the beauty of having that
experience combined my business partner
he's got three other businesses that so
we've combined all that say now this
works we've proven that it works and now
we're just tweaking it to get better all
the time and become experts in that in
that area so yeah absolutely right you
just want to quietly build and when we
speak to the sports guys and we'll work
with some of them are Premiership
championship etc and they might have
hundreds of thousands in the bank by
Satan I don't you know don't spend
hundred thousand do your first one if
you were doing your first by to learn
the process when they're going through
their first buy that mortgage or
abridging product all that stuff that's
a headache for sports on the first time
they do it so I said look learn I'm
gonna help you with it and I have like
one of our us pieces we go above and
beyond so I'm there sometimes at 10:00
at night helping people for that form
but that's the things I'll do because
that's what I'm prepared to do for them
but that's the thing I say don't get too
excited about buying ten all at once do
it one on one the amazing thing what
you're doing I mean similar to similar
to me because I think that I've seen a
lot of very good people making serious
serious money and then they're pushing
boxes and Sainsbury's two years later
and it's it's it's sad so I think what
you're doing it's a really good leash
yeah it's it's it's don't run
we can walk and I think I say today now
we've got some guys who are on their
second and third property where this
etcetera now they're thinking oh I'm
ramping up cuz I understand how it works
I understand what it's like to be in a
reefer and in some what it's like for
someone to cost a bit more on a reefer
you know in the Sun extra they
understand oh yeah this will let in the
first day this one let on in a week all
that stuff you learn that you have to
experience it you don't know until you
experience it and it's so easy to see
top line figures in property and think
oh that's easy
trust me when you buy properties can
take two or three months to buy even
when you're really fast and things that
they're trying to be fair sometimes
lenders can be a pain I think that you
can't learn all there is to know by like
reading books and stuff it's it will be
it will begin to open your eyes you've
got to actually do it but at the same
time don't do it until you have read the
books and got the education because then
you could end up making big mistakes
what advice finally what advice would
you give to someone that was weighing up
whether to come to the crash course what
would your advice be I think everything
we spoke about was about education and
taking action I think the first step is
of course if if someone's interested in
something like property they're just
starting to learn about different
inspirational people etc but you kind of
go and do it you've got a start you have
to start somewhere and I think going out
and meeting these people you'll see
people on different levels of their
journey some just starting out that will
be like most people some are on their
first one or two some are 10 20 30
there's still things to learn and
there's nothing better than learning
together it's normally a positive vibe
on all you know for yourself bringing
that positivity and a bit of inspiration
as well you know if you want to do well
in anything you've got out of that
tenacity and you have ambition to really
grow something I think sometimes being
around people who are doing something
there's nothing better you it's like a
Robert case I can all understand you
become the five people who spend most
time with we want to be with people if
that's your goal to grow so you want to
be people who are doing it I'm sure when
you came to the crash course there was
only about 50 people it could have been
yeah back in there but it wasn't like
now things like that happening so you
know it's amazing how things change and
I said I didn't go very fast you know in
my portfolio so sometimes I like to
bring the tone down and say look you can
go at your own speed and sums some
people are 120% they're going going
going and some do really well some
actually stretch themselves too far and
you see there goes a negative mine was
actually more of a slower journey and
now am i starting to ramp it up more but
even now even though I'm full-time it's
not stretching myself to too much we're
still we're still going at our own pace
and hopefully and maybe in year two
you're saying I can go a bit faster now
I know I've done 20 Potter steadily
you're looking at your mistakes as you
go and you do and you can you're going
with people and there's a saying that
says if you want to go fast go alone but
if you want to go far go together and
the fact that we start right now we're
still friends you know you're doing
great dude I really appreciate you
coming on thank you ever so much
great this evening well
you